Peter Brown here with a gamespot news
update earlier today a developer working
on the lords of fallen RPG said that
they're having a harder time pushing the
game to 1080p on xbox one compared to
the PlayStation 4 the executive producer
of the game told IGN we're working very
hard right now to deliver PlayStation 4
and Xbox one in 1080p but I can't
confirm whether it's possible it's
probably easier for me to confirm it'll
happen for PlayStation 4 because it
appears on this one we're almost nailing
it for xbox one though it's slightly
tougher and we're still working on it
the game is set to release this fall so
nothing is set in stone yet as far as
the frame rate goes he went on to say I
think if we have to choose between
resolution and frame rate will probably
choose to go full HD 1080p and have a
stable rock solid 30 frames per second
rather than try to lower the resolution
and push it to 60 frames per second
because we believe this game looks
pretty good so we'd rather have a decent
resolution to show it off for more lords
of the fallen and next-gen gaming news
stay tuned to gamespot com